someone despises me
that's their problem
realize that you have something in you
more powerful and miraculous than the
things that affect you
and Make You Dance Like a puppet
no carelessness in my actions
no confusion in my words
no imprecision in my thoughts
no matter what anyone says or does
my task is to be good
if it's endurable
then endure it
stop complaining
not to be driven this way and that but
always to behave with Justice
and see things as they are
not to assume it's impossible because
you find it hard
but to recognize that if it's humanly
possible
you can do it too
do not let others hold you back
the object of life is not to be on the
side of the majority
but to escape finding oneself in the
ranks of insane
limit yourself to the present
the first rule is to keep an untroubled
spirit
the second is to look things in the face
and know them for what they are
never esteem anything
as of advantage to you that will make
you break your word
or lose your self-respect
receive without Pride
let go without attachment
you have power over your mind
not outside events
realize this
and you will find strength
be tolerant with others
and strict with yourself
get busy with life's purpose
toss aside empty hopes
and get active in your own rescue
everything
is born from change
stop allowing your mind to be a Slave
to be jerked about by selfish impulses
to kick against fate
and the present
and to mistrust the future
waste no more time arguing about what a
good man should be
one
think of yourself as dead
you have lived your life
now take what's left and live it
properly
learn to be indifferent to what makes no
difference
the struggle is great the task divine
to gain Mastery Freedom happiness
and tranquility
courtesy and kindness that Define me
today I escaped anxiety or no I
discarded it because it was Within Me
in my own perceptions
not outside
there is nowhere that a person can find
a more peaceful and trouble-free retreat
than in his own mind
so constantly give yourself this retreat
and renew yourself
true Good Fortune is is what you make
for yourself
Good Fortune good character good
intentions
and good actions
anywhere I could lead your life
I can lead a good one
when I do help others or help them to do
something
I'm doing what I was designed for
think about the expansive time
and how brief
almost momentary
the part marked for you
think of the workings of fate and how
infinitesimal your role is
the responsibility is all mine
no one can stop me from being honest or
straightforward
to love only what happens
no greater Harmony
the happiness of my life depends upon
the quality of my thoughts
it is not death that a man should fear
but he should fear never beginning to
live
there is a limit to the time assigned
you
and if you don't use it to Free Yourself
it will be gone and never return
there is never any need to get worked up
or to trouble your soul about things you
can't control
these things are not asking to be judged
by you
leave them alone
why should you feel anger at the world
as if the world would notice
be like the cliff against which the
waves continually break
but it stands firm and tames the fury of
the water around it
if it is not right
do not do it
if it is not true
do not say it
if you are distressed by anything
external
the pain is not due to the thing itself
but to your estimate of it
and this you have the power to revoke at
any moment
ask yourself at every moment
is this necessary
your days are numbered
use them to throw open the windows of
your soul
to the Sun
if you do not
the sun will soon set and you with it
the best revenge
is not to be like you're in me
do not indulge in dreams of having what
you have not
but wrecking up the chief of the
blessings you do possess
and then thankfully remember how you
would crave for them if they were not
yours
the things you think about determine the
quality of your mind
your soul takes on the color of your
thoughts
because a thing seems difficult for you
do not think it impossible for anyone to
accomplish
never remind people about yourself
because those who value you
remember
and the rest doesn't matter
choose not to be harmed
and you won't feel harmed
don't feel harmed
and you haven't been
do not act as if you were going to live
Ten Thousand Years
death hangs over you
while you live while it is in your power
good
here is a rule to remember in the future
when anything tempts you to feel bitter
not this is Misfortune but to bear this
worthily
is good fortune
when you arise in the morning
think of what a privilege it is to be
alive
to think
to enjoy
to love